so I wrote this book because I was
really curious about billionaires I
wanted to know who they are how they got
rich and what are they doing with their
immense wealth I also wanted to know
what are they like as individuals
between teaching at Brown University for
26 years and now being at Brookings for
about 6 years
I've had encounters with a number of
different billionaires and so I think my
experiences reveal some interesting
tidbits about their mentality and their
viewpoints
I was once visiting a billionaire friend
of mine in Palm Beach and of course he
has a beautiful place right on the water
overlooking of the ocean and one morning
we were sitting on the patio overlooking
the water when a helicopter flew very
noisily right down the coast kind of
completely disturbing the serenity of
that morning and my friend rolled his
eyes and said oh that's my neighbor and
it turns out that instead of driving his
car 2 miles down the road to go to the
golf course this guy flew his helicopter
so this is an example of billionaires
annoying other billionaires in 2012 I
had an experience of a billionaire
annoying me I was asked that year about
the possibility of Donald Trump speaking
at the Republican National Convention
and I joked in the article that
Republicans should actually send him on
an all-expenses trip around the world
because if he actually spoke at the
convention he would bring the party
nothing but trouble
now I didn't really think too much about
making those comments but the morning my
quote appeared in the paper I got a call
from Trump's assistant requesting my
email address and shortly thereafter his
assistant sent me an angry missive from
the villa near himself and what Trump
had done was he pasted my comment about
him into the body of the email and then
he wrote in big black bold letters
Darrell you are a fool best wishes
Donald J Trump
which you know I really appreciated the
best wishes there I actually have this
note framed in my office the only thing
I didn't understand was he put air
quotes around fool and that made me
think that I was actually being more
stupid than a typical fool and you know
prior to that interaction I hadn't
realized there were actually gradations
in being a fool and that's the the note
that he sent but it was the first
billionaire that I met at Brown
University who propelled this book and
that actually is Ted Turner about 20
years ago Ted Turner came to brown to
give a lecture and his visit was
noteworthy because he'd actually been
kicked out of brown for disciplinary
code violations mainly involving wine
and women
and I'm not sure if it was in that order
or not but so we hosted him for a
lecture and he came with his then wife
Jane Fonda so you know this is a big
deal for the university as a glitzy
occasion and he actually gave a very
funny speech he said that his favorite
thing about having a ranch out west was
being able to urinate off the front
porch which for this ivy-league crowd
that was a little racy for us but you
know we laughed but then he turned more
serious and in his remarks he discussed
wealth and he said the first million is
the hardest after that money begets
money and everything else is easier
wealthy people have social economic and
political connections and those things
make it much easier to make money so I
thought a lot about that comment during
the 2012 presidential elections we saw a
number of super super wealthy
individuals pour a lot of money into the
campaign of course the most famous
individuals are doing that where Charles
and David Koch who devoted hundreds of
millions of dollars seeking a first to
defeat of President Obama and then now
of course they're very active in this
year's a campaign Sheldon Adelson wasn't
far behind he was an early supporter of
Newt Gingrich but then shifted to Romney
during the general election but it turns
out that they are not the only
billionaires who are politically active
Michael Bloomberg the
has put fifty million dollars into
fighting gun violence he's also very
active in promoting immigration reform
George Soros supports a number of
liberal grassroots organizations Tom
Styer is probably one of the less known
of the politically active a billionaires
but this year he pledged a hundred
million dollars to raise public
awareness about climate change
so in researching this phenomena I
discovered it's really not just an
American phenomena but it is a global
development billionaires actually have
run for office in twelve different
countries around the world and most of
the time they actually end up winning
the most famous is Berlusconi in Italy
but more recently we have the case of
poroshenko who is the new president of
Ukraine the political activism of these
and other billionaires raises important
questions about excessive political
influence conflicts of interests and
poor transparency when it comes to money
and politics we are seeing what I call
in the book the wealth of ocation of
politics and society at many different
levels and many have written about the
economic consequences of well I wanted
to look at the political impact of great
wealth
so there are 1645 known billionaires
according to Forbes magazine and 492 of
them live in the United States and I
think it's really important to
understand the impact they're having on
our political process one of the things
I wanted to look at is there are several
aspects that I think are particularly
important in terms of the context in
which this activism is taking place one
is the high level of income
concentration that we're seeing here I
have a chart from Thomas Piketty and
Emmanuel Saez which shows the dramatic
rise of income concentration between
1913 and 2012 income concentration
reached a high this is a among the top
1% in terms of the percent of the income
that they earned in 1928 it reached a
high point of 21% meaning the top 1% of
America
at that point in time got 21% of the
income but then you can see in the years
after a World War two the income
concentration dropped it actually
reached a low point of 8% in 1976 and so
people say you know the wealthy always
are going to be wealthy and every
country has this when you look at
American history
it actually fluctuates up and down
policies make a difference and of course
what we've seen in recent years is it's
now come back up and is now back to
about 20% the top 1% have very
distinctive political views compared to
the general public political scientist
Ben page
Larry bartels and Jason see right did a
very interesting study where they
compared the political views of the top
1% versus the general public in the
United States they used identical
questions they asked a battery of
questions to each of them and then
essentially compared the results and
what you can see here is on a variety of
issues here I talked about Medicare
views about schools and also views about
health care on all of these issues the
top 1% have distinctive views and they
generally prefer a more limited role of
government 87% of the wealthy favorite
cuts in Medicare in order to reduce
budget deficits compared to 27% of the
general public in regard to schools a
35% of the rich believe government
should spend whatever is necessary to
ensure that all children have a good
public education compared to 87% of the
general public that feels that way and
then on healthcare 41% of the wealthy
say they are willing to pay more in
taxes to provide health care for all
compared to a 59% of the general public
so the rich are very politically active
they obviously have a lot of money they
have distinctive views perhaps one of
the more troubling things that I
discovered in the course of doing my
research was what one wealthy individual
described to me as they get a senator my
strategy I heard that term and I thought
ok tell me about this what are you
talking about and what this individual
said
is that there are some ultra wealthy
individuals who practice this particular
strategy I mean we all see congressional
gridlock we see the hyper-polarization
the extreme partisanship that afflicts
our a process it turns out that big
money is in the middle of some of those
problems that wealthy people have
discovered that the way to stop
legislation is to find a sympathetic
senator and give him or her to basically
use obstructionist tactics
this can include placing holds on
appointments that you don't want and I
should point out these are secret holds
so we generally don't know who is behind
the hold or what their particular reason
is we can just see the fact that you
know these appointments languish for
months and months without any movement
you can filibuster to stop legislation
so there are a variety of different
activities that fall within this
category the New York Times actually had
a very interesting story about this
involving Bill Ackman who's a Wall
Street financier and his campaign
against Herbalife Ackman has been on
this campaign against Herbalife he has
you know lots of complaints about it's a
business model and has shorted the stock
he was able to get Massachusetts Senator
Ed Markey to write letters to the
Securities and Exchange Commission as
well as the Federal Trade Commission
demanding an investigation into this
company and the day that that
investigation became public the stock
price fell which was a big help to mr.
Eckman it's kind of similar to a recent
New Yorker cartoon that some of you may
have seen which shows this wealthy man
in this really nice office with real
really big windows saying I owned one
plane two yachts four houses and five
politicians
when you look historically we often have
had various organizations in American
society that help us keep track of what
is going on in the political process and
of course the news media is a big part
of that they have been the major
oversight organization reporters are the
people who help the rest of us keep
track of what is going on in the
political process it's a way to kind of
assume some balance in the system but of
course what we've seen in recent years
has been the news media have been
devastated by the financial crisis and
the growth of free information on the
Internet and this has been especially
harmful at the level of state government
here I have a chart drawing on research
conducted by the American journalism of
review which basically shows over time
the number of journalists covering state
government they've done surveys they
found that in 1998 there were 513
journalists that were basically working
full-time to cover state government by
2003 that number had dropped to 468 by
2009 which is the last year in which
they have done this survey that number
was down to 355 I think most of people I
talk to think if you actually did this
survey today that number would be a lot
less than a 355 and so as a result of
both the opportunities and the lack of
oversight some billionaires have shift a
lot of money into state referenda and
state policy advocacy knowing that there
is actually a lot less oversight there
than what we see here in our nation's
capitol
so we've seen people get very involved
in same-sex marriage marijuana
legalization immigration pension reform
Obamacare you name the issue there often
is a big money behind this so the
problem that I see in thinking about
this whole topic of money in politics
especially when it comes to billionaires
is a lot of people suffer from
ideological blinders when I talk to
liberal
they love it when liberal billionaires
spring an action and spend a lot of
money and you know if you support
immigration reform you think it's great
that Michael Bloomberg is investing a
lot of money if you're worried about gun
violence you think that is a good thing
conservatives love it when they're rich
people do exactly the same thing but I
think what all of us need to do is
really step back and think about the
system as a whole we need to think about
the impact of great wealth on government
on society and on economic opportunity
in the conclusion of my book I argue
that we need policies that promote
better transparency and promote broader
economic opportunity Henry Ford was
someone who understood the value of
reasonably paid employees here's a
picture of him he was famous for paying
his factory workers double the going
rate and when people asked him about it
he said look I need customers to buy my
products it's in my self-interest for me
as a factory owner to pay my workers a
good share and not only because it helps
them live but they then can purchase my
cars and so businesses need workers in
order to thrive in to be successful so I
suggest that we need more equitable tax
policy we need public investments in
education and health care
and I close the book with a personal
story saying that I am living proof of
this argument because in the last
chapter I tell the story about being a
young kid who woke up one day with
swollen Jones joints a sore throat and a
high fever a doctor looked at my
symptoms and immediately sent me to the
hospital I had developed rheumatic fever
which is a bacterial disease that
attacks the joints and the heart valves
and at age 11 I had rheumatic fever
now today nobody in America gets that
disease it is a developing world illness
there are still many kids in Africa who
get this and they don't have access to
antibiotics many of the people who get
this even today end up dying by age 20
but in 1966 when I had rheumatic fever I
was fortunate that there was a miracle
cure penicillin
that had just gone in the market a few
decades earlier I had gone into a mass
production and through a publicly funded
Hospital I was cured I went on to a
productive life I went to a public
university got a graduate degree taught
in the Ivy League for 26 years and then
ended up teaching at what I view as the
world's top think-tank so I won the
lottery
in terms of life fortunes Dale who is my
friend who's also shown in this picture
was not quite as fortunate as I was
after this picture was taken he was in a
farming accident and lost his big toe he
never got much of an education he
struggled economically his entire life
and he died last year so we have two
young boys who grew up in exactly the
same area two very different outcomes
there obviously are many things that go
into life fortunes and explain why some
people had an easier time than others
but we need public policies that keep
the American dream alive for the next
generation of young kids thank you very
much
so what I'd like to do is to invite our
panelists up and we will continue our
conversation
I'd like to welcome our distinguished
visitors today all these individuals
have great experience in various aspects
of American politics they've reported on
many of the major controversies in the
field
Peter Overby is the power money and
influence correspondent at National
Public Radio I do have to say I like
that title a lot thank you
that should be very busy in this town
none of it has rubbed off on me though
so I'm sure many of you have heard Peter
on the radio he's been at NPR since 1994
he's covered all of the most important
money in politics issues of the Newt
Gingrich funding issues Bill Clinton's
fundraising problems soft money the
passage of mccain-feingold the Jack
Abramoff scanned all various Supreme
Court decisions citizens united and
McCutcheon and then now the recent rise
of super PACs he has won several awards
such as the Alfred I DuPont Columbia
silver baton and also the radio and
television Correspondents Association
annual Award for Excellence Ruth Marcus
is a columnist and editorial writer at
the Washington Post she focuses on
American politics and domestic policy
she's been with the post since 1984 as
she joined the National staff in 1986
and has covered a wide variety of issues
including campaign finance the Justice
Department the Supreme Court and the
White House she joined the editorial
board in 2003 and began writing a
regular column in 2006 John Harwood is
the chief Washington correspondent for
CNBC and is also a political writer for
The New York Times he writes the weekly
column a political memo for the paper
and in addition to CNBC John offers
political analysis on NBC's Meet the
Press and also the PBS show Washington
Week in Review among other television
and radio programs
Brody Mullins is a reporter for The Wall
Street Journal based in DC and in that
position he covers business lobbying and
campaign finance he started his career
at the national Journal's Congress daily
and later at
roll-call where he covered Congress and
lobbying he has twice won the Everett
McKinley Dirksen award for distinguished
reporting on Congress he also won the
George Polk award and received an award
from the National Press Club for best
political reporter under the age of 33
so I want to start with a backpack well
that's still a great way to start your
career so I'm going to start with Peter
so you have great expertise in money in
politics what do you see is the
political impact of billionaires and has
their influence changed over time well
billionaires influence has changed just
because when you start looking at the
history of money in politics there
weren't any billionaires yet you have
the inflation factor but there's always
been big money in politics that's that's
a given in America one popular example
is Eugene McCarthy's campaign in 1968
was basically financed by eleven guys so
you know you have that history what you
have now is after a period of more more
disclosure more openness or campaign
contribution limits you have arise in
unlimited contributions and arise in
non-disclosed money being prominent in
the political system the 501 C 4 s and
other 501 C groups with a mainly C force
and you talk about the you know the
finite number of billionaires in this
country we don't know how many of them
are active in politics we know a few of
them you know we know the Koch brothers
we know Tom Steyer George Soros etc but
most of people on that list we don't
know if they're politically active or
not and if they're active through 501 C
4 s we can't know unless it leaks so
you know there's an undefined
it's an unanswerable question well wait
a minute but I asked it so you have to
answer by death I know that's that's
actually very helpful to have that
background so Ruth what do you see is
the political impact of billionaires
well you know it's very interesting
because in some ways you could sort of
go to the history and say and even kind
of leaving aside the inflation point and
you know when millionaire was a big deal
with the the capacity of big money now
big money has to start with a B but it
used to start with an M the capacity of
big money to influence politics has
always been there you know go back to
robber barons but go to the modern era
and look at Buckley v Valeo the the the
public concerns that were unleashed and
correctly so actually on citizens united
to some extent have their Genesis in
Buckley the capacity of individual
billionaires to spend as many billions
and as many of their billions or
millions as they want by themselves in
politics has been there since 1974 and
actually one question we can ask is not
why is this happening now and wring our
hands about it but why wasn't it
happening previously because in it
limits on individual spending in
independent expenditures have never been
in place I do think that it's
fascinating to think about that question
because there has been a change in the
culture where there seems to be more
willingness on both sides of the
political spectrum or throughout the
political spectrum if you throw in Mayor
Bloomberg to spend millions and be kind
of proud of it I couldn't agree more
with the question that issues that in
concerns that Darrell and Peter have
raised
about secrecy because it is in fact the
toxic nexus between big money and
secrecy where you have the biggest
problem and the scariest unknown figure
in your presentation is the number of
reporters at state houses because when
you take big money and you take secrecy
and you take away coverage you have a
huge problem but that said I think that
the the the willingness of these
billionaires to be kind of unabashed
about their desire to influence the
political process is to some extent mean
we know about a lot of shape Sheldon
Adelson spending because he was proud to
tell us about it
the koch's who used to operate in even
more secrets they have just decided to
embrace it people like Tom Steyer kind
of want the coverage um it's a
fascinating maybe to have the capacity
to amass billions you also have to kind
of have the ego to want people to know
it and know how you're spending it but
in some ways in addition to the more
troubling developments I think that's a
kind of interesting one so Brody you
focus on distance lobbying and campaign
finance what are you seeing in Surrey uh
well the first thing I want to say that
my comments are just my on my own
comments not of you know my billionaire
Rupert Murdoch who's a really good guy
just trying to help the country but I
think so I think that part of the the
way the system that's been developed now
it's sort of a law of unintended
consequence that came from the 2002
campaign finance reform legislation
where at the time businesses and unions
and billionaires could give unlimited
sums of money to the political parties
and at the time everyone thought that
was a bad thing
and so we passed
legislation to ban these unlimited
contributions to the political parties
and a few years later that money not
able to go into the political party
started going to these outside groups
and it took a few years some potatoes to
get to the system that we are now but
what we basically used to have is a
system where people could give million
dollar donations to the Republican Party
the Democratic Party and it was
disclosed and we knew who was giving the
money and it went to two sort of center
to two forces that were were bringing
politics together or tried they're both
trying to be big tents and we had at the
time Southern Democrats we had
Republicans in New England we had people
who are all across the spectrum in both
political parties and they came to
Washington and they hate sort of
compromise because people from various
different parts of the country agreed
with each other whether they're
Republicans or Democrats and now you've
taken that money and said hey you can't
go to the political parties it goes to
now these outside groups which are for
the most part pretty extreme so you
don't have candidates coming to
Washington who are supported by senator
fiying group students instead you have
candidates who come to Washington who
are in general more extreme
you've had no Republicans in New England
you have no Democrats for the most part
in the south California is almost all
Republicans the coats are Democrats the
coasts are Democrats the middle
countries Republicans and so you come to
watching people can't compromise and I
think that is it was really all in
effect an unintended consequence of the
2002 reform gone what's your view of the
political impact of billionaires first
of all I think we will have an
interesting controlled experiment if
sales of this book make you a
billionaire we will find out and if this
happens I will be happy to disclose that
publicly
well I must say I think of topics like
the effect of billionaires a little bit
like I think of the topic of say media
bias which conservatives complain about
it's true it's a factor but I tend to
think it's not as large a factor
independently as the critics fear it is
and you talked about that in your book
you know does does Obama's election
re-election is that proof that money
doesn't determine election outcomes I
think it doesn't it influences them but
it's one of a number of factors and you
know Brody was describing really
structural changes in American politics
that to me are the greatest determinant
of election outcomes and those have been
going on for some time like decades
since the 1950s our politics have sorted
out I also think that if you look at it
more broadly you can make an argument
that the real problem is not or the
problem with money in politics is much
bigger than 1% maybe it's the 15%
because the way we've had a divergence
of life fortunes and economic success in
our country you could say you could look
at our system and say that public policy
is made for the interests of
upper-middle class people not
necessarily billionaires only because of
the rise of income inequality and the
stratification of the society and the
way that perpetuates itself through our
education system and many other issues
so I think it I think it matters I think
money tends to balance out whether it's
billionaire - billionaire money or
billionaire - online money I was so
struck in 2004 when Howard Dean in a
phenomenon that really had nothing to do
with billionaires I believe it was a
third quarter of 2003
raise more money in that quarter than
Bill Clinton had raised in any quarter
when he was running for re-election as
president United States so you the
technology and and information
infrastructure that we have makes it
possible to innovate and figure out new
ways of balancing the effects of people
like the Koch brothers or George Soros
okay so John was mentioning the election
impact in 2012 I want to ask about the
2014 election so Harry Reid is of course
regularly attacking the Koch brothers
Tom stires next-gen climate action super
PAC has run ads totting the Koch
brothers I think that's a little risky
myself but Crossroads GPS advertising
has attacked steyr as a quote California
billionaire who it says stands to profit
from blocking the Keystone pipeline so
I'll just throw this out for anybody in
the pano who wants to address it how is
all this dueling billionaire activity
going to affect the 2014 elections if at
all actually I think I would argue not
very much at all it's a little bit and
we saw this when Senator Reid was having
his kind of daily attack on the Koch
brothers to sort of say what's this
about and really what it's about to me
it's not to sound too cynical is they
don't have anything else to talk about
on both sides and we're better to be
cynical than on this panel with this
group I just wanted to you know stake
out the cynicism portfolio look I really
think that that it's a little bit on
both sides of a base revving up
mechanism to go on the attack the other
guys billionaires front but I don't
think it's the kind of thing that
resonates with most voters and I really
think what most voters seeing this stuff
should say is okay that's fine but what
are you all about
wait which actually gets me to something
I wanted to challenge John on which is
food part
a challenge in the nicest possible way
because you were saying that you thought
things would work themselves out
billionaire versus billionaire and they
really take your point which i think is
a really good one about the powerful
impact of internet advertising and
somewhat leveling the playing field but
in terms of billionaire versus
billionaire how do you stake that
assertion against what I think are
they're really kind of troubling
differentials in Darrell's chart about
attitudes of the these weren't
billionaires but these were the top 1%
different really clear ideological
differentials from the general
population which definitely tilted in
the right direction the rightward
direction not Corrections or excellent
jeonyul
well sure but are you talking about you
know a disparity in a partisan sense or
disparity between the interests of or
the political views of billionaires
versus everybody else well I think it
might sort it might end up being the
same question right if you're a
billionaire and you think there should
be less government spending on health
care or less government spending on
education you're gonna probably
gravitate toward one political party
rather than another yes but a couple
things first of all the that is also in
the service of the point that I was
making more broadly about people with
money not billionaires but people with
money upper middle class people they
care a lot more about deficit reduction
than ordinary people do so to some
extent that is that's not a function of
billionaires it's a function of income
inequality in different ways of looking
at the world but I but you also have as
the gene McCarthy story indicated that
Peter mentioned you've got billionaires
who individual individuals who are
willing to spend money in the service of
values that are out of step with their
class and and in fact the the trend the
Democrats improvement politically
speaking
with people with money is an important
factor in level leveling what we're
talking about Democrats are doing a lot
better with people with both
postgraduate education successful baby
boomer baby boom liberals who have gone
into business and so I think that gives
them the capacity to respond to the COPE
libertarian shrink government kind of
worldview maybe not in a
dollar-for-dollar way but in a way that
is sufficient to advance competing
arguments so Peter and Brody how do you
see money playing out in the 2014
elections I think that it's what I'm
sorry that the money or the billionaires
either okay I think that we we see hints
that the billionaire issue resonates
with voters I just did a story last week
note that mentioned the Senate race in
Michigan where they had just the League
of Conservation Voters had just run an
ad tying the Republican candidate Terri
Lynn land to the Koch brothers and
Suffolk University pollsters were
polling just as that ad was ending and
they get to the open-ended question when
what's the first thing you think of when
I say the name of the candidate and for
Terri Lynn Lynn land a significant
number I think was 4% of the of the
respondents said first thing they
thought of when her name was mentioned
was Koch brothers big business that
basically that phrase so you know does
this stick till the election I don't
know but the fact that it's registering
at all that way I think it goes back
basically to Harry Reid kind of setting
the stage for the Democrats to do this
kind of advertising and
coke groups attack Tom Steyer crush
roids tax Tom Steyer I think that that
just plays into it
Brody do you think these attacks and
counter-attacks are going to make any
difference or is the election going to
end up being decided on other issues you
know it's hard to say us stepping back a
little bit we're still in a period of
elections where most of the money is
still being spent by kanays and
political parties for the old system and
the the money being spent by the outside
groups and donated by billionaires is
still not a majority of the amount of
money being spent now obviously is just
a few names who are putting a lot of
money out there but so far elections are
being battled the way we want them to be
battle which is by candidates that's
going to quickly change this may be this
election actually may be the tipping
point where outside groups and
billionaires and millionaires spend more
money on the election than kanays
themselves and if we keep going in this
direction we'll get to 2016 and beyond
where all of a sudden the candidates
aren't being able to get their own
messages out because these other groups
are battling above them about their own
campaigns and I think that's gonna get
that's a point where I think it's a
pretty dangerous for democracy when the
candidates who are running for office
aren't even allowed to control their own
message and we're not there yet but
we're heading there and there's no signs
of legislation to change anything and I
think that would be a pretty scary
prospect it becomes this de lecture next
election the one after we ought to
remember that ads matter less and
messages matter less than they did
before so much of our politics is
structural and it is well known to the
vast majority of voters what team
they're on and their cultural
identification they're you know people
who care about the environment and
income inequality and don't like the
prevalence of guns in our society know
what team they're on and know which way
to vote to advance that team and the
same is true of people on the other side
the you've got increasing stratification
of our politics by race white voters
overwhelmingly in very large numbers
vote for
Republican candidates and blacks and
increasingly Hispanics are locked down
for Democrats and so the the influence
of the attack ad and other campaign
materials I think it's it's on a pretty
narrow band of voters when we look ahead
to 2016 it strikes me that Democrats
haven't quite decided how they feel or
what they want to do about billionaires
because on the one hand you have Harry
Reid who's kind of fighting them rather
publicly on the floor of the Senate and
then you have this ready for Hillary
super PAC which is not quite her super
PAC but it's ready to be it's yeah it's
ready to be is signing up billionaires
and so I think Democrats can't decide
whether they should fight them or join
them so when we look ahead to 2016 how
do you see this whole thing evolving and
you know both on the Republican side as
well as on the Democratic side anybody
wants to jump in one thing that we're
seeing already is that with the Koch
brothers in to a lesser extent with Tom
Steyer the billionaires who are building
their own ground organizations which you
know you keep going this direction they
do TV ads you do a ground organization
the the Koch Network has its own voter
database just like a political party is
where is the line between a political
party and and something like the Koch
Network I'm not saying that the Koch
Network is a political party but they
are doing a lot of the things that a
political party does well you mentioned
super PACs and so I think it's really
important to continue to distinguish
between the kind of billionaire spending
that we're talking about because it's
already but we can gloom and or discuss
the rise of the super PAC as a force in
American politics but at least we know
through super PACs what billionaires or
millionaires or the rest of us are
contributing and spending
and I think that that my big bigger
worry is not billionaires banding
together and billionaires super PACs but
billionaires spending money that I don't
even know about and to that extent I
guess I'd argue that the fault isn't in
our billionaires it's in the rules that
we've allowed to be written that allow
them to operate without any sunshine on
them the fact that we have a tax code
that doesn't that allows tax-exempt
organizations to engage in what anybody
out there you know from first grade on
understands as political activity is
really a criminal public policy and it
needs to be changed the IRS understands
it needs to be changed the IRS needs to
get itself out of the business of
politics and everybody will be better
off in the FEC needs to get itself into
the business of these things but we
either need regulatory changes or
legislation to make that happen and I
think we all understand the entrenched
interests that work against that so
which leads to a 2016 set up that
doesn't just see the explosion of super
PACs spending this disclosed but the
continuing rise of 501 C 4 501 C 6
spending that's not disclosed Bertie
yeah I I couldn't agree more I think you
know all of us as reporters obviously
are gonna be in favor of disclosure but
the problem with our election system now
is and often times we don't know who is
spending money so you know with ten
years ago we were to sit down all get in
this room and sit down try to come up
with the worst possible system for
financing our campaigns would probably
end up with all we have now where people
could spend as much as money they want
to and they don't have to disclose who
their names are and the cans themselves
don't control the message and that's
where we are now into it's a it's a
pretty terrible system and the
disclosure part I think is the worst I
would say Darryl to pick up on your
point about ready for Hillary
I don't think Democrats are ambivalent
about how they feel about billionaires I
think every single one would be welcome
if
they show themselves to be on the
Democratic team and bring their
checkbook it is it is not a billionaire
is not a disqualification for the
Democratic Party as long as you're on
their side and they've got some and and
they'll use them as best they can and
again you know in the influence of of
these super wealthy spenders I think I
think back to Sheldon Adelson he bet his
money on Newt Gingrich you know how
effective was that where did where did
that go
you had another one I forget the name of
the guy who invested very heavily in
Rick Santorum I'm yeah Frese and I'm
sure any Democrat would be delighted if
he spends a billion dollars on Rick
Santorum in next primary election but
you know you there's there's only you
can make a difference but there's only
so much of a difference you can make hey
why don't we open the floor to questions
from the audience there's a gentleman in
the very back with his hand up so we
have a microphone that will that will
come back to you if you can give us your
name and your organization and those of
you who are watching the webcast if
you'd like to submit questions that you
can do through do so through hashtag
billionaires oh yeah thank you very much
i'm lauren hershey about 30 years ago i
was a guest scholar here at Brookings
welcome back I thank you I come back as
often as I can I want to thank the
panelists wonderful discussion lots of
questions I could ask as an attorney who
helped to break up AT&T but I want to
try to make it easy I'm a Virginian
there was a federal trial in Richmond
recently 177 thousand dollars bought
some favors will you please comment on
that
what what what comment sorry what could
you be more specific in what I think in
about three years there'll be a Supreme
Court decision called US v you know
Robert and marine O'Donnell McDonald
sorry or vice versa McDonald versus US
so the question is how does that play
out in this psyche or the consciousness
of the American voter today and I could
give you a sort of a other side of the
coin there's there's two new populism
going on in the United States one is the
Tea Party the other is the left wing of
the Democratic Party senator from Ohio
and senator from Massachusetts represent
them I invite your comments what what
else is there out there that is
happening that is Illustrated or that
you would interpret or comment on from
these two phenomena the new populism
left-right Democrat Republican and the
Macdonald conviction in Richmond about
two weeks ago well so about the
MacDonalds I would say that the outside
observer cynical voter the corruption
that was disclosed there and that the
jury decided was criminal behavior
they're really just ratifies what voters
many voters at least think is business
as usual I mean I I've always been
struck Peter you probably Brody John you
probably have as well by the degree to
which voters act many voters actually
think the system is so much more corrupt
than it actually is that there are you
know lobbyists coming with bags of money
and plopping them on the desks of
lawmakers for their own personal use
I mean what's really interesting about
the merit reporters to and um what's
really interesting about the Macdonald
case is that if he was dealing with a
campaign donor and getting campaign
contributions that were disclosed and he
was simultaneously doing relatively
minor fish
relax for this donor would there be a
criminal case there at all the benefits
probably not the benefits were going to
him personally and that really
transformed it but I think from the
point of view of voters it's probably
all of a piece of this big disgusting
mess that they think of as a Washington
and be politics yeah the the I think the
the public doesn't recognize the
distinction the Washington runs on that
campaign contributions aren't bribes I
would just say that I think elements of
the left and right populism you refer to
flow from the same source which is that
our system our economy is not delivering
rising incomes to families in a way
anywhere like we did in and and I think
that engenders a you know people get
different notions of why that's true and
some of it could flow from the
corruption of the system some of it
could flow from immigration some of it
could flow from the increasing wealth of
the 1% and the ways in which the 1% tilt
the playing field but all of those
things I think the underlying fact is
that people are anxious and scared about
their economic futures and that plays
out in the political process a Kristine
has a question from our webcast audience
thanks Terrell you touched down a little
bit in this and with your remarks
earlier but for the larger panel can you
get into the your perspective on the
psychology of billionaires what drives
them what makes them tick
who are these people great question I
will say one thing that I don't I don't
think I have any friends who are
billionaires but I have a friend who
might be close to that and
I think that I'm struck in talking to
him at the way in which he oddly in my
opinion feels besieged by the political
system and like this whole notion of you
know pit pitchforks and people coming
after people with money that engenders a
sort of an attitude of trying to push
back really hard I remember having a
conversation with this guy at a college
reunion clearly before the 2012 election
and he was asking me - Obama hate
festival people so much and I I didn't
know what how to answer it because it
seemed like a crazy question actually
but there is a sense that and I don't
know if there's a psychologically
there's a psychology that's part guilt
or or if it's simply you know
self-protection but there is a sense of
everyone else who's not doing so well
being after them and a little bit
comical to my way of thinking but that's
that's the only exposure I've had to
what I think might be responsive well I
I don't know any billionaires or I
didn't until I met Darrell I like your
optimism by the way you know this may be
counterintuitive but IIIi don't or a
counter in conventional wisdom but I
don't think that billionaires spend all
this money on elections for a pure
business point of view I don't think the
Koch brothers say we need to change
policies so we can make more money I
think it's how they feel ideologically
whether you're on the right or on the
left and I could be wrong but you know
these guys make billions of dollars a
year and they're only spending a hundred
million dollars they think it's gonna
affect their business wouldn't they
spend more money if they really thought
this went directly to their bottom lines
so I feel the same thing I prefer
Sheldon Adelson I don't think that he's
spending money on casino regulations
he's spending money on other causes he
has so
there's some money on casino regularly
some money but Peter Thiel I just don't
think a lot of these people if they
thought that these elections are so
important to their own bottom lines they
would spend more money but I think it's
more just ideological but Adelson seems
to want to be a person of power within
the Republican conservative movement you
know he yeah he threw away his money on
Gingrich but the result of that was that
now all the candidates are coming to him
saying hey how about me though you know
I I think for him he likes to be in a
position of power and and his his
spending in 2012 cycle helped establish
in them that way you know I think one
thing that we haven't touched on is the
really interesting and it kind of goes
to the what are they motivated by are
they simply trying to protect their
wealth or are they trying to promote
their worldview and I think it's
probably more the latter and so one of
the things that I think is a really
interesting distinction is the
difference between billionaires spending
their money on candidates and
billionaires spending their money on
causes and it strikes me in part because
of the countervailing influence of
individual donations through the
internet that billionaires are spending
money on causes and you write about this
I'm Daryl actually could be a more
powerful and depending on what your
position is and where the billionaire's
sort themselves out more pepper more
pernicious role in terms of the impact
on state referenda my billionaires spent
a lot Steve Bezos I don't know if he
thinks of himself that way spent a lot
of money on a copy that you're not going
to get far if you called Steve
you know what there you go I'm done
pirates fire can we like undo the tape
what was like not enough caffeine this
morning Jeff Bezos my billionaire spent
a lot of money on referendum in
Washington State on marriage equality
which passed great use of money I would
sis I would venture to guess that his
2.5 million there was a lot better
return on investment than 2.5 million on
Newt Gingrich or whoever his canned
individual candidate of choice might
have been and so I think that's a really
interesting distinction to raise on the
billionaire and billionaire incentive to
be involved in this in psychology of
involvement
I think that's leaving me John I think
that is an important point kind of the
state-level activity that we're seeing
especially around referenda policy ideas
and so on because the thing is if you
think about kind of you know two or
three or five million dollars going into
a medium-sized state like if you want to
talk about ROI it's like you could
really have an impact and so in some of
these campaigns you end up with
one-sided campaigns and if you have a
weak media role that can be a bad
combination
if there's a lot of competition if you
know it's a fair campaign and there's
spending on both sides you know that's
not something I would worry about myself
just wait to see what happens when they
try to outlaw helipads at golf courses
like here yeah that Palm Beach guy is
gonna be in big trouble
Peter if I can get a microphone over
here it's coming up from behind you
thank you I'm Peter shut lis retired
from Brookings I'm struck at the
moderation of the panel on this issue
you know this money is always influenced
the u.s. politics it's not new there's
Democrats there's Republicans so it's on
both sides and I think this is a much
more nefarious issue development than
the panel seems to believe on and let me
throw two thoughts out and get your
feedback two negative thoughts one is
the rising public opinion polls that
show the American public thinks the
system can be bought higher and higher
percentages I think it's in that mid 80s
or something and when the public has
such a negative view of the influence of
money that's terrible for the whole
system a second negative impact is in
the past a would-be candidate needed to
develop a broad base of financial
support get lots of contributors to run
now all you need is one billionaire you
don't need to develop any message that
affects the broad swath of the people
that's broadly accepted you go Adelson
behind you and that's all you need a
second major negative impact of
billionaires on money reactions Engrish
didn't when the Republican nomination
and Obama was reelected as a surface
level response but I think that first of
all I don't think it's the case that you
look back and candidates in the past
they didn't have wealthy patrons who
were making it happen for them that's
everybody from Ronald Reagan who had a
group of very very
richard nixon gene McCarthy is the I
just I don't think it is that radically
different and I don't think that it is
that you're a guarantee of success I do
think it's corrosive that people believe
the system is corrupt but again I think
a lot of that flows from their feelings
about their own economic prospects yeah
what they're getting out of birdie you
wanted to jump it on that yeah I mean I
agree that money has always been in
politics out but I was trying to say
earlier is the promise is I think how
the money is being spent is no longer
being run through the political parties
which bring candidates together instead
being run by unaccountable outside
groups who often don't need to disclose
their the source of the money or who
they're spending running for I think
that's the problem so you end up having
candidates come to Washington who are
beholden to the extremes of either party
and not Canada to come to Washington
with a sense of more balance I think
that's the problem sort of how the money
is flowing not that there is money and
if I could add an international
component to this because as I mentioned
earlier billionaires have run for office
in 12 different countries and often have
been very successful versus Kony is of
course the most famous example but when
you start looking at what happens once
these people actually are in office I
mean the point that Peter raises about
public cynicism like in all of these
countries
there always are charges of cronyism
conflicts of interest insider dealings I
mean you can kind of look at Italy
Thailand Georgia where there have been a
lot of evidence of this of course in the
developing world you know they don't
have the rule of law that we have they
don't have the economic opportunities in
many of those countries they have a
small number of billionaires the thing
that actually makes me most optimistic
in terms of the future is the fact that
we have 500 billionaires and on most
issues there's some diversity of
viewpoints among them but you could go
into other countries there may be three
billionaires or five billionaires or
seven billionaires they always have very
close
relationships with the people in
government and that it leads to massive
public cynicism in those countries and
perhaps even less effective regulation
and disclosure than we have absolutely
Stephen thank you my name is Stephen
Colt I am I guess scholar here at
Brookings working in international
entrepreneurship as a foreign policy
tool I think that the point that was
made about the corrosive effect of all
of this is a really important one
because it's one of the reasons why
there's so much excitement about your
book we all know this is happening and
here is a book that talks about it and
one of the things that I thought was
especially interesting were the
under-the-radar
revelations that you made the Ackman
Marquis herbal life example we all know
about the few household name
billionaires and the candidates they've
supported what we don't know is what we
don't know and so when you match that
with the chart that you showed about the
decline in investigative journalism
which is why I especially wanted to ask
this question of this panel of
journalists you have a very nervous
making situation and so my question is
seems to me that there are two answers
and I'm and I'd like to hear your ideas
about which of these is most realistic
to happen versus your question don't
give us the answers well the first note
the first question is what is the how do
we increase the transparency given the
numbers that you showed of journalists
declines or second option is campaign
finance reform and the likelihood of
that so I actually can say something
optimistic for a change which is
actually I would suggest that among
major news organizations there are is
actually more resources dedicated toward
covering money in politics now than
there was when I first started writing
about it in 1995-96 Deb you weren't
doing then Peter but it was not a it was
not a boom area of journalism and we
learned after the 1996 fundraising
scandal that it was really
paying a lot of resources and attention
too and I think there is it much there
is no major news organization without a
reporter dedicated I'd venture to guess
toward covering money in politics that's
a really good thing it doesn't
counterbalance the failure of many news
organizations to have local and state
level reporters or to even have
reporters dedicated toward covering
their congressional delegations I think
about the Duke Cunningham corruption
which was there for the looking at you
looked at his financial disclosure forms
you went to look at the properties he
had and it was evident on its face it
took reporting to bring that to light on
the broader question of the prospects
for campaign finance reform you know
what they are I will sound a a more
pessimistic note than Ruth he just wants
to fight with me about state-level
journalism when I was in the Tallahassee
Bureau of the st. Petersburg top three
and eighty four we were engaged in a
process that we split the cost with the
Miami Herald called the greening of the
legislature and we we it was staff
intensive we had several people working
on it we had okay we had every single
action or vote that was taken in the
legislature we associated the money with
the legislators and how they voted and
that was a theme of our coverage well my
newspaper yesterday announced 5% pay
cuts for every single person who worked
there and warned of impending layoffs
the paper has shrunk dramatically from
the size that it had so is the Miami
Herald effect the herald Strunk even
more and so I think that those that's
just an emblem of the data that you saw
in in Daryl's presentation of the
shrinking number of people covering
state legislators on this topic and
every other topic yeah
Bethy of someone who has a questionnaire
this gentleman right there yep my name
is Michael Boekel I'm a reporter at the
Center for Public Integrity on the money
in politics Pete and going back to 96
and 2000 2002 the last round of campaign
finance reform laws came out of these
scandals and I was curious if you
thought if the panelists thought that
attitudes towards wealth and big-money
had changed months since then if people
were wrong to be outraged about those
things if we were allowed to give more
money to the parties directly you know
if if it was sort of a situation where
if you know bush or Obama had guests
coming back to the Lincoln Bedroom maybe
there would be raffles so some small
dollar donors we're good to go as well
as the big dollar donors but what does
it you know really take to have a
scandal that would affect things these
days the whole business of political
money and fundraising all that is much
more out in the open than it used to be
so here's a the the baseline level of
cynicism is a lot higher when I when I
started on the speed you know can't
campaigns did not want to talk about
their fundraising lobbyists didn't like
to talk about their lobbying and all
that and now you know you know the
campaigns are bragging about how much
money they raise and you know the
parties are bragging about it the only
people who aren't bragging about it or
the see fours basically and some of them
are bragging yes if not disclosing yeah
yeah so
you know that if there's it's a lot more
out in the open therefore I think that
the the potential for scandal is greater
because it's more generally understood
what's going on you know what what the
norms are and you know when you go past
those norms and I think it's easier to
tell the story if a billionaire is
involved then if you know some corporate
lobbyist is involved so you know maybe
you know we're on the train headed down
the tracks for the it to get to get even
more cynical do bonified can go for even
more citizen oh my the laws are made by
people who win and the people who win
are people who who do well under the
system so they have no incentive to come
to Washington and change the rules so
that some other guy can win down the
road and that's really a problem and
that's why in campaign finance and in
ethics reform
nothing happened to tell there's a
scandal that happened with Abramoff and
the post that happened with 1974
Watergate that's how we got campaign
finance in the first place so it really
will take a scandal for there to be some
sort of change I'm gonna out cynic you
and say that the capacity for scandal
may be greater but the capacity to
respond to scandal is less I think back
to 2000 campaign during the primaries
there was a group that popped up I'm not
remembering its name that was a 527
organization which was a political
organization but it wasn't back then it
didn't have to disclose its donors it
was spending but then seemed like an
unbelievable sum which my recollection
was two to three million this was during
the Republican primary campaign and we
couldn't figure it was a think in
support of I can't remember whether it
was in support of John McCain or in
support of George W Bush somebody else
here we've got a less creaky memory than
I am is gonna jump in and help
they were tacking delighted brothers it
was the way I was given to say it was
the Wiley brothers but I'm not sure
whether they were attacking McCain or
supporting him in favor of Bush but it
all of a sudden this thing popped up on
the horizon I was an editor at the time
and my reporter went out and basically
just by dint of banging on people
these Wiley brothers came forward they
had no responsibility to disclose this
527 well within a few months Congress
had actually passed McCain push because
back in the days when McCain cared about
campaign finance reform McCain pushed
and Congress passed legislation that's
still on the books that requires 527
groups that are operating outside of
regular political committees to disclose
their campaign spending and donations
that happened within the election cycle
as I recall our capacity to respond in
that same election cycle or even in
anticipation of the next election cycle
seems to me in response to a similar
scandal to be vastly reduced yeah I
probably should at this point in spirit
of full disclosure explained my cameo in
the 1996 Clinton fundraising scandals in
1997 Republicans were investigating and
Fred Thompson had a committee and I got
a call one day from an investigative
reporter at the Boston Globe who also
happen to be a friend of mine who said
I'm want to know why you attended one of
the Clinton fundraising coffees and why
you didn't disclose that to your readers
of The Wall Street Journal and I said
what are you talking about I of course I
didn't go to Clinton fundraising coffee
and he says well I've got a document
that says you did well it turned out
later that what happened was the White
House databases got kind of screwed up
because there's a John Harwood who
worked for The Wall Street Journal there
was a John Harwood who was the Speaker
of the House in Rhode Island who later
went to prison for corruption and these
things got mer actually know that John
Harwood
and these things got merged and so he
wrote in the paper the next day that I
denied having intended although he
actually did not go to prison for
corruption there were a bunch of other
people who did but okay Christine has a
question from our webcast audience
thanks can the panel talk about any
differences if there are any between
sort of the establishment established
billionaires these Sheldon Adelson's of
the world and whatnot with the emerging
money delete coming out of Silicon
Valley the Mark Zuckerberg of the world
the emerging elites gonna be a lot more
reflective of younger generation in
terms of being socially liberal I mean I
think generally speaking there is going
to be a more democratic group or at
least more democratic on a certain set
of issues than the older money group
that we're talking about although
they're also more libertarian more
socially liberal more marriage equality
more probably reproductive rights more
well you see it in Tom Styer focus on
environmental climate change issues the
other aspect of that that is interesting
is you know what happens when the
current billionaires start passing away
like what happens to their money like a
number of these people are pretty
conservative in their views they often
have children or grandchildren who do
not share their viewpoints we actually
have had a interesting example of this
the late harold simmons who was a dallas
a billionaire who passed away last year
some of his fortune has gone to two
daughters who have supported Hillary
Clinton they've supported Barack Obama
they support reproductive rights harold
simmons himself said barack obama was
the most dangerous man in america
because of the threat to the free
enterprise system so i'm not sure how he
feels about what his daughters are going
to be doing with his money
top you had a question waiting to whip a
microphone coming up to you
oh one comment about the sort of parties
versus the outside groups I think it
really mischaracterizes how our politics
has evolved if you look carefully at the
parties and how involved they are
strategically and every other way in
elections especially the swing elections
they've never been as influential today
as as they've been even most of the
really big and influential super PACs
are informally attached to the party so
that we really do have two big team
operations and all of the emphasis on
what's the chamber doing within the
Republican Party to support the
establishment is a pittance of what's
really going on
the parties are ideologically polarized
they're finding their allies among
billionaires and others and that's where
the game is and having the money come
directly to them would probably not make
much of a difference electoral e but it
might make the donors a little more
influential than they are right now
picking up on the last thing Darrell we
now have a movement among some
billionaires a campaign to give back
half and I'm just curious it outside the
immediate political arena what can you
say about what's happening in the in the
billionaire community I mean beyond
referendums interest and big issues but
other things that might come closer to
public goods I mean a number of the
billionaires that I have looked at are
actually very forward-looking in their
policy agenda like they're kind of
thinking down the road in terms of
robotics and you know what kind of
social impact that's going to have kind
of offshore communities Peter Thiel is a
libertarian who has been
that there's research on stem cell
research I mean these are individuals
who are very visionary that's in in
large part how they made their money
like they saw something that was not
happening
they found a niche and then they ended
up making money on it and so in their
philanthropy they're kind of thinking
long term in exactly the same sort of
way and as you point out Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett have proposed the giving
a pledge in which billionaires give away
at least half of their money during
their lifetime so there are 1600
billionaires around the world slightly
less than 10% have actually signed up
for that many of them are in the United
States there hasn't been that much
interest outside the United States I
know they actually went to China to try
and sign up
Chinese billionaires for The Giving
Pledge had a big dinner at the end of
the dinner nobody signed out so but we
do have the very interesting case
Alibaba just went public this week Jack
Ma the leader behind that firm is
actually starting to do some
philanthropy inside China he's worried
about air pollution and so he's focused
very much on the environment of course
he's cognizant of kind of you know
billionaire activism can get you in
trouble
in your home government so he keeps
telling government officials I want to
work with you like I'm not working
against you on this issue so I think
there are lots of interesting things
going on in that area we're out of time
but I want to thank our panelists peter
ruth john and brody I think your
comments really added a lot and I really
appreciated learning your insights and
for those of you who want books we have
them out in the hallway so thank you
very much for coming
[Applause]